nous pourrions euh ralentir un peu la vitesse anémométrique
jusqu'à euh peut-être
50 nœuds
bro
cercle vers la gauche
c'est juste par ici d'accord d'accord merci
20 secondes d'
accord
je veux le regarder ce soir je suppose que
quelque chose à regarder a
eu
euh
comme ça
bien  c'est à travers ses utilisateurs à cette
vitesse à cette hauteur
et on a le on a le
combat et le vol à droite
et là par exemple pour
sortir du plan si on considère que
c'est suffisant on continue tout droit l'unité
la sortie du  tourné ici serait
juste vous savez
continuer à couper à travers la rivière et à le
laisser derrière vous voyez
sinon si nous faisons 30 secondes ou plus
ou une minute nous le suivrons et nous essaierons
vous savez
ouais nous sommes juste
bien ici par exemple pour moi en ce qui
concerne la rivière est trop haute
le paysage est tellement pourri d'
accord alors maintenant nous sommes sur eux d'accord
plus loin d'eux
cercle autour de la gauche
plus loin des animaux pas au
-dessus d'eux
c'est tes mots
je ne fermerai pas
maintenant en su  ch un cas
tu coupes
et tu fais un gros plan ok
amnésie
dézoomer vite en plan large
connaissant exactement le gros décor grosse scène ok
mais en fait ce qui aurait été bien
ici c'est que tu sais juste aller un peu
plus loin et plus près donc  qu'ils ils
commencent à galoper
et on sort du magasin comme ça et
sur eux on se
bat encore
quel coup car bien tiré ici maintenant
plan large
on le fait tu sais 30 secondes et c'est
assez on a ça ok bon alors maintenant
tu zoomes  eux hé le zoom
arrive
ok tiens les comme ça c'est
merveilleux laisse la caméra les tenir ne les
laisse pas sortir de la caméra
ok
laisse les partir au galop
et laisse les
ok